So David,
how did you configure the chair?
>> So you can see here my final
configuration for this chair.
I ended up with a 160 gram chair.
It cost $16 based on
having four metal legs.
I didn't give it arms.
I gave it a metal back.
And of course the 100 gram
metal seat that was required.
As far as how I actually did
this though, like before,
I started off by writing out
the initial constraints we were given.
The chair has to cost less than $16.
It has to have 100 g metal seat.
And it has 100 g metal seat.
And that seat has to cost $10.
So 100 grams times $0.10 per
gram means $10 for the seat.
After this, however, we're already
pretty close to our price limit.
So the plan I'm using might specify
that when we're getting within a certain
range of our price limit to operate
under a heuristic that calls for
minimizing the cost.
That heuristic in that
plan might then say,
find the part that can be
minimized the most next.
That part would be the arms.
The arms had a range
from 0 grams to 50 grams,
meaning that arms are not
even required in our chair.
So to minimize our costs, we're
going to go ahead and cut the arms, and
say that our arms cost nothing.
Now our plan might recognize that we're
no longer quite as constrained by our
price, so we're going to choose the next
most important part of the chair,
which might be the legs.
Given some information that
the plan has about the ideal legs,
it might choose to have four legs,
that are ten grams each and
are made of metal,
which gives us a cost of $4.
Based on the $10 seat and
the four dollar legs,
we now know that we have $2 left for
our back.
The plan may have a heuristic that
says it's ideal to match materials or
the plan may have a heuristic that
says that metal is the optimal
material to use.
So it may choose metal.
And given $2 for the remaining money and
a material of metal,
it can derive that 20g is
the mass available for the back.
And now that all of these individual
variables have been assigned,
we can then see that the final mass
is 160g, and has a cost of $16.
At most $16 meets that constraint.
And we have our 100g
metal seat over here.
>> That's good David.
This important note that David used
several different kinds of knowledge.
First, he had knowledge
of the general chair.
He knew about the components,
he knew about the slots, but
not necessarily all the fillers for
the slots.
Second, he had heuristic knowledge,
he used the term heuristic.
Recall that heuristic stands for
rule of thumb.
So heuristic knowledge about
how to go about filling
the values of some of these slots.
Third, explicit list is not
just knowledge about legs and
seats and arms and so on,
but also how this chair,
as a whole,
is decomposed into its components.
That is one of the fundamental rules
of knowledge and knowledge-based AI.
It allows us to structure the problem so
the problem can be
addressed efficiently.
Note that this process of configuration
design is closely related to the method
of constrained proposition that we
discussed in a previous lesson.
Here are some constraints, and
these constraints have been propagated
downwards in the plan
abstraction hierarchy.